what makes you great at story and how
did you get good at it my big education
in story was really when I worked for
Blake on his second book just because
the the thing that I had to do in that
role as sort of his research assistant
was watch 50 movies and not just watch
them once but watch them over and over
again and you know break them down and
sort of figure out what the structure
was and how they were working right so
so that was like my crash course into
story before that I worked in the
entertainment business I read scripts I
was you know writing coverage and
talking about scripts with people but it
wasn't until I did that and had that
sort of like immersion into just the
rhythm of stories that I really I felt
like I sort of you know absorbed it and
it was like in my bones after that so
that was a great experience and I think
that that is that was my first part not
my first but that was probably the the
biggest impact on my understanding of
story wow that's really cool so would he
give you a list of movies to watch oh
yeah so in the second book there are 50
movies that are broken down sort of beat
by beat and so I think overall we
watched more than 50 because you know 50
made the final cut but it was it was
watching the movie once just just sort
of you know let it wash over you and
then it was watching again paying
attention to structure and then it was
watching again taking notes and trying
to figure out like okay is this sort of
timewise is this kind of where the act
ends and is this where it escalates and
things like that and and trying to like
really make sure that we understood it
so each of those movies I watched at
least three times and that was I think
if you if you want to sort of have an
understanding of the rhythm of
storytelling that's a great exercise
just sit in your apartment for several
months watch movies non-stop watch the
same movie over and over again because
you'll you'll just sort of like absorb
it you know well reserve one or two of
the films of those fifty that was really
it was just a little bit difficult to
grasp the structure and some of the
around it oh yeah I mean I think crash
was a tough one to break down because
it's it's not traditional right it's it
has a three-act structure but because it
follows different storylines it makes it
harder to kind of like follow that one
through line all the way through right
obviously but so that was that was
probably one of the harder ones to just
figure out how were they making this
work in a way that felt like it was all
one story that had sort of a beginning
middle and end yet we were being told
this one story through three separate
storylines or three or four I can't
remember and then when you would watch
these these different movies I mean you
said they were more than 50 would you
write coverage no so um well I think
that back it wasn't coverage like we
think of coverage but I was writing kind
of the the structure breakdowns of them
like here's the you know opening image
here's this here's what happens in the
setup here's the inciting incident and
all that stuff and how long would would
each like movie Oh probably three pages
yeah yeah schnapps this of the story you
know can you tell us how you met Blake
Snyder oh sure I my first job in LA was
working for a manager producer as an
assistant and Blake was a friend of his
and so he would just come in the office
and was such a friendly genuine person
that he of course made time to talk to
me the assistant before he would go in
and and have a meeting and so I got to
know him over time and he was very
supportive of writers in general and of
me being interested in screenwriting and
so when he wrote his first book he gave
it to me to sort of Bay to read and give
him my thoughts and tell him if it was
useful and I think I still have that
that caught that original copy and then
when he decided to write the second book
he asked if I would sort of come be his
research assistant so then that's when I
started watching all of the movies for
him Wow any any memories anecdotes just
from just seeing how he worked gosh not
that I can share okay no I think the
lasting memory that I have a Blake is
just that he was so enthusiastic about
story so if I ran an idea by him for a
script that I wanted to write
he would instantly you know latch onto
it and get excited and you know start
pitching ideas and that enthusiasm I
think is what sort of set him apart
because he you know you could even be
sort of lukewarm about your own idea
that his enthusiasm would make you fall
in love with it and excited to write it
so and did you think that his books
would have such an impact I mean yeah
there's so many great books out there
but his is like in another stratosphere
in terms of the reach yeah I I remember
reading the first book and and he one of
the things that he wanted to know was do
you think this is useful do you think
Riedel writers will be able to use this
and I remember thinking like this is
amazing I can't I can't imagine anyone
not being able to get something out of
this so I think just the way he sort of
simplified and distilled you know the
same things that we all talked about
with three extra three act structure and
you know he really he really took the
idea of three act structure and sort of
made it accessible and easy to
understand even if you're just starting
to learn about story structure or
screenwriting in general so I think that
that is what makes his books you know
lasting and have such a big impact on
people great yeah I know he even wrote a
letter to David back it was at 2008 or
2009 it was so cool I was so cool yeah
everybody people still people still
submit log lines to that email address
yeah and does does anyone answer or
usually I do yeah oh okay yes it's - I
mean it's still going it's it's own it's
kind of like the artists way it's gonna
always yeah kind of be in there I mean
people love it it's you know I it's
controversial at times all right like
there's some people that think it's too
formulaic or whatever I think that those
people are sort of not are sort of
missing the spirit of it yeah but but
yeah I mean people rave about it still
and that are just finding it now so
you